إنهم يتخذون موقفًا دفاعيًا
ضد مشكلة متنامية في
مضيفات الطيران الذين يتدربون على ضرب
الكوع
وقلع الركاب العدوانيين المحاكاة
مع ركاب حقيقيين يزدادون
عنفًا أكثر من أي وقت مضى
، وربما تموت ، فأنت بحاجة
للدفاع عن نفسك بأي ثمن.
حراس
يوجهون ثمانية مضيفات من خلال
دورة الدفاع عن النفس هذه ،
وهي الدرجة الأولى التي تقدمها وكالة أمن النقل منذ أن
توقف التدريب مؤقتًا بسبب الوباء ،
إنه لأمر محزن أنه يجب أن يحدث ذلك.
الغياب
، هل أنت خائف أحيانًا قليلاً ،
نعم ، تصعد
على متن طائرة مليئة بالناس
وبعضهم ليس سعيدًا جدًا
ولا تعرف أبدًا ما الذي سيحدث.
الحوادث التي
تقول إدارة الطيران
الفيدرالية إنها تصاعدت بشكل كبير في الوثائق الفيدرالية
بالتفصيل كيف صرخ الركاب على الأرض
وأخذوا يقذفون  مضيفات طيران ck
آلاف المرات
منذ بدء سياسة عدم التسامح مطلقًا في
وقت سابق من هذا العام
في مايو ، قام راكب بضرب مضيفة طيران جنوب غرب جنوب غرب البلاد
مما تسبب في فقد اثنين من
أسنانها وفقًا لاتحادها ،
فلا يوجد نسخة احتياطية تبلغ 30 ألف قدم لذا فإن
هذه الطائرة  في الجو به طاقم
يجب أن يتعامل مع
المشكلات ويتعين علينا التأكد من
أنهم مجهزون بالكامل
ويقول المسؤولون الفيدراليون أن بعض الركاب
يتغذون بالكحول ولكن
معظمهم يقاومون بشأن التفويض
الشامل للنقل الفيدرالي
الذي يتكون  ثلاثة أرباع
جميع الحوادث التي تم الإبلاغ عنها هذا العام فقط ،
إنه أمر سيء للغاية هناك سارة نيلسون
من جمعية مضيفات
الطيران تقول إن شركات الطيران يجب أن تدفع لموظفيها لأخذ
هذه الدروس
ويجب على الحكومة الفيدرالية أن
تطلب من أطقم الطيران أن
تحضر كل عام حتى نتمكن من الحصول على تلك
القوة  الذاكرة وتكون قادرًا على الاستجابة
عندما يهاجمنا شخص ما على الفور ،
وعلى استعداد للتحرك هنا يقوم المدربون بتدريس
تقنيات ال  يمكن أن يكون منقذًا للحياة
مثل
تثبيت مهاجم مسلح
بسكين ، لكن وكالة أمن النقل
تقول إن بضع مئات فقط من الأشخاص قد
التحقوا بهذه الدورة بعد أن
أعادت فتح التدريب في أواخر يونيو / حزيران ،
مضيفة الطيران المخضرمة دونا أونيل
تقول إنها يجب أن تأخذ  هذه
الدرجة
للتعامل مع نوع من الركاب
أصبح شائعًا جدًا ،
ولا أريد أبدًا أن أضطر إلى استخدام أي من
هذا ، لكنك تعلم إذا كان عليّ
بالتأكيد أن أشعر
بثقة أكبر بكثير بيت مونتين cnn
شروق الشمس في فلوريدا